envie de fraises en ce moment chez
qu'est ce que j'ai envie de parler en
son nom
c'est toi quand le fils fred qu'il y ait
un petit imprévu qui fait aussi que l'on
a pris cette décision d'aller peut-être
un peu vite
c'est ça qu'est ce que ben voilà on
attend un petit bv tulle entendre le
pire de notre petit confort vous êtes
tombés sur un peu comme ça et puis
finalement c'est une belle surprise
alors qu'est ce qu'on vient de faire et
on vient d'acheter une maison familiale
pour
pour le new escapade balançoire
peut-être demain soir là avait utile
parce qu'elle a un temps et mathieu mais
mes jumeaux d'amour qui sont là tout
bien tout frais voilà il y en a un qui
est célibataire
non c'est bien on peut le dire
maintenant on peut dire ouais ça veut
dire ouais moi j'aurais jo célibataire
aussi toi je sais il est sorti la dorna
police pour ça peut te dire je peux
sentir célibataire à plus 40 km là c'est
à 2,3 mètres mais tu as senti quand vous
êtes à tuchan quoi pour moi alors je
sens que ça y est tu as trouvé la vraie
on peut pas mettre une belle rencontre à
gerland contre toi tu l'as bien ou mal
porté chance est vrai face à l'inaction
ça me fait plaisir
bah forcément avec quelqu'un qui a été
touché par par ma personne
isabelle civis et y vit c'est vrai pour
quelqu'un qui t'as vu voilà la suite au
passage échanger et au final les bains
pour l'instant voilà où nous prendre
notre temps et puis on verra
pourtant pour l'instant y'a rien de fait
intéressante et santé récent c'est juste
récent ce dernier un petit croche y
intégrant un petit creux xianning traité
- peut-être quoi j'étais franchement je
n'ai fait que je sois témoin c'est un
match et si tu veux j'anime le mariage
haut rendement témoin qui est
malheureusement n'a pas pu être témoin à
travers cette expérience ça serait assez
bons il ya clément ok avec mon coach et
ça va mon clément java c'est remercie au
temps de te voir aussi alors mariée au
premier regard est ce que c'est vrai
tout ça est ce que ces trucs qui est ce
que c'est maintenant
maintenant que c'est fini il faut nous
dire la vérité on a besoin de savoir
pour vous est ce que cette munition est
une mascarade
franchement pour moi oui pourquoi
maintenant vus le résultat et vu comment
ça s'est passé en fait faut bien
comprendre que moi moi là j'avais
j'avais posé ma candidature seul au
départ donc on n'a pas postulé ans en
live où et quand ils m'ont rappelé m'ont
dit tu parlais de ma famille tout ça et
à ce moment là j'avais dit que j'avais
un frère jumeau lights on dirait et là
ils se sont dits pour la verte duction
il faudrait qu'il le fasse aussi avec
toi ça serait le top est ou non après
j'ai rejoint le faire qu'après je
l'embarqué avec moi bien sûr il avait
envie de le faire c'est un rêve de jeune
célibataire
elle est endettée célibataire et du coup
bah on l'a fait ensemble mais j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait du coup c'était
vraiment à tout prix nous avoir dans le
programme et j'entendais trop souvent
pendant les castings les jumeaux vous
adore on vous veut absolument
on espère qu on va vous trouver une
compatibilité et je pense qu'à un moment
donné bas les compatibilités elle
s'était peut-être parce qu'elle était et
je vous somme du sud parce que je vous
dise en titre et sincère dans votre
démarche
moi je suis vraiment déçu je suis
vraiment déçu presque en fait marianne
c'est à l'escalet mais quand quand j'ai
vu qu'après le voyage de noces en très
peu de temps
il n'y avait rien qui concordait avec ma
vision des choses et même les
comportements les attitudes qu'on avait
qui étaient totalement différentes
bah c'est là que je me suis dit en fait
je me suis même senti un peu trahi par
là même un problème avec rachida coup
voilà c'est sûr que bah c'est une
déception c'est une déception parce que
lorsqu'on vous dit franchement je vous
dit tout je sens que je sais c'est juste
un casting doigt parce que moi
généralité mais oui je pense que voilà
j'aurais fait exactement comme m6 comme
la production de m6 on vidait j'aurais
dit les deux ces deux personnages
incroyables
je vais tout faire pour le retrouver
quelqu'un de compatible avec la wii
c'est en fait c'est un peu le jeu de la
télévision mais c'est pas ces je ne
trouve pas que ce soit une masse ya
renoncé après je vous dis tout après
voilà moi je m'en fous ça y est après
moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a déçu c'est de
voir que très rapidement en fait j'étais
pas compatibles finalement avec marianne
sur des tas de choses en fait sur des
attitudes et comportements je trouvais
que des fois elle était même immature
vis-à-vis de certains comportements et
c'est ce qui a fait qu'à un moment donné
moi je me suis dit très très rapidement
faut stopper parce que même dans ce
qu'elle dans les explications par
exemple qu'on se donner pour essayer de
donner nos explications à la production
tout ça même carrément des fois
l'inventaire des trucs et caen et je me
suis dit c'est pas un comportement
mature donc alors là j'ai millions qu'il
dit aussi que vous aviez demandé même
vous avoue marié le même jour on
aimerait ça c'est vrai c'est ça ouais là
c'est un rêve de jumeaux donc cette
histoire on va dire
ils veulent tous faire assez c'est la
chose positive pas jusque là
tout pareil que dubaï alors crime aux
toits pour toi ce n'est pas le cas du
tout toi tu étais tu étais heureux de
faire cette aventure voilà est pour toi
c'est pas du tout une mascarade
bon en fait faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que ça reste quand même une
aventure humaine qui est énormément
remplie d'émotion donc on peut vite se
faire submerger par l'émotion et on peut
vite se perdre après il ya autre chose
on n'a pas eu le même mariage moi je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans leur
mariage comme eux ils savent pas ce qui
s'est passé avant de venir chaque mois
chaque tragédie a pris pour combien de
10 à la compatibilité la compatibilité
mais il ya aussi le côté humain et le
côté humain fait la validation ou non de
ce mariage
sans ça moi je les ai vécus vraiment à
2000% l'aura aussi en même si l'issue
l'a tous vu hier on s'est séparé il ya
aucune animosité entre nous on s'est
toujours soutenu ans est toujours entre
aidez moi j'ai compris tout s'est
ressenti être un peu tard elle pas
forcément elle a pas su gérer donc j'en
ai combattu pendant un moment donné mais
c'est normal c'est un mode agile et où
les coupes ne peuvent pas marcher ainsi
sur regarder ça tous les couples là il
ya quand même cette coupe soit disant
ultra combativité que trois qui se
et alors si on s'éclaire ça alors
c'était la médecine soudé avec la
machine ne déchire on joue avec le
mariage le mariage oui ça crie ça que je
suis d'accord avec isabelle médiatique
que dans la vraie vie
guillaume pardon il ya aussi des
histoires at et bien sûr oui mais il ya
un couple sur deux qui divorcent
aujourd'hui non pas moi j'en suis
d'accord rapidement son lot de toi
puisque tu vois d'habitude tu n'aimes
pas les émissions que tu dis de télé
réalité va on est pour le coup dans une
émission de télé réalité qui porte
vraiment son nom pour le coup parce que
c'est de la réalité qu'on filme et du
tout en tout cas pas bien berceau du
figaro qui est formidable damien qui me
dit les couples mélina yannick et mines
trade viennent d'annoncer leur
séparation sur les réseaux sociaux il
faut également donc c'est vrai qu'il
peut y avoir là il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de sincérité je remets absolument pas
encore parce que vraiment vous m'avez
tirer les larmes et je vous trouve
formidable mais en revanche c'est le
principe même de cette fameuse
compatibilité scientifique en amour il
n'y a pas de science et pas de
mathématiques ya pas de lampe ap
tbilissi
c'est pas une question de facilité c'est
juste un moment donné quand on arrive
les jours des castings ou des rencontres
avec les experts on a quand même un
panel énorme de question on a beaucoup
de réponses
on a beaucoup de choses à raconter sur
notre vie donc si on part du principe
que moi j'ai répondu correctement que la
personne avec qui on m'a mis une
compatibilité répond correctement et
sincère forcément nécessairement c'est
là où je rejoins non géraldine permet de
mailler c'est là où je rejoins géraldine
un moment donné le match et là on fait
si la fréquence de vos réponses mais
comme dans un casting je le sais a fait
un casting en fait on s'est dit c'est de
nous doit tout de suite avec et de la
guerre est très bien ensemble mais avec
l'oreille on le voit tout de suite la
compatibilité assurant deux secondes on
rentre dans la vie du direct mois en
2007 de direct sur moi la seule chose a
pris effectivement ou la prod peut
intervenir c'est sur des choses qui nous
demande qu'est ce qu'on veut moi j'ai
demandé un caprice et saint yves a
bouclé ce serait qu'il allait
prochainement d'un kebab
on va vous demander si ce n'est qu'après
j'ai demandé un camion dit qu'est ce que
tu veux moi je suis comme vous fan de
enrico macias j'ai dit je le corps dit
comme ça c'est bienne moment à vienne
chanter amant marié jeu le mendiant de
l'amour ils m'ont dit ça va être
compliqué la directrice de rappeler
christ m'appelle me dit on peut pas mais
il va te faire une vidéo pour te faire
un coup pas mal et félicitations sauf
que le jour où il a fait la vidéo c'est
un vendredi c'était shabbat donc nord /
c'est vrai mais moi je voulais dire
c'est de l'amour à la tête chez j'ai une
chance car il y en a mais des m'amuser
voilà les mots je suis chaud c'est la
seule chose qu'on avait demandé en
rigolant mais voilà dans l'est tu sais
quoi est fait l'avenir un jour et demi
qu'on voit sur la tête de ma mère j'ai
le soutien de téléphone non plus ouais
mais il était en concert après marie à
nouveau du coup est alors qu'on est au
top ce diable il ya plein de gens là qui
me disent les trois célibataires on n'y
croit pas on a envie de se positionner
il ya plein de gens qui aujourd'hui je
me concentre beaucoup sur je profite de
cette image de surfer un peu pour les
associations d'ailleurs j'étais chez
sofiane chez solaris au soir il est venu
avec toi exactement je connais bien là
donc je fais un bisou jean luc fournier
la caméra est dotée au cpe mais d'amour
d'amour n'ont pour l'instant non je me
suis reconcentré sur mes proches ma mère
ma soeur
ah oui et puis sur le boulot sur sur des
choses essentielles de la vie et puis il
ya ça redescende un peu vraiment énergie
morale merdoie moi et tu dois avoir
beaucoup de sollicitations c'est vrai
que ta mère était formidable tu dois
beaucoup de sollicitations
les projets détresse oui oui oui je le
dis mais qu'est ce que tu te méfies mal
pour l'instant ouais c'est ça c'est
parce qu'en fait la médiatisation s'est
passé ça c'était quelque chose de très
nouveau pour nous et à gérer c'est pas
c'est pas forcément ceinture c'est leur
gardien aujourd'hui il a pété un câble
regardez c'est bien chaud
[Applaudissements]
cassel complète
il fallait animateurs eux
disons que je vois quelqu'un que j'aime
bien mais voyez passer ou non je me
disais moi je vous verrai grave oui je
trouve que vous iriez vous avez une
grave en sambre et vous êtes très beau
merci beauty et marie pierre et brique
aussi vous voulez rien produit tpb
d'actifs a ni le nombre n'est pas au
baril se compliquer l équilibre de
vidéos c'est votre cas c'est votre style
ah oui totalement et complètement
et alors ben non je vous trouve très
ferme en mai après voilà vous vous
cherchez quelqu'un de simple et je crois
que suis un petit peu trop sauvage voit
un petit peu trop bas du tout du tout
ils cherchent l'amour tout simplement et
c'est la définition de la simplicité
pour vous cet automne dans la simplicité
et la sophistication suprême
restons essentials non mais j'ai pas dis
vous êtes un peu la sones célibataire si
vous deviez sonné entre les trois
garçons lequel serait le plus beau style
tout de suite voilà marié au premier
regard vous pourquoi ce que vous ne
semblez plus sincère il ya l'air plus
sérieux non c'est moi parce qu'ils
croient eux une licence est si parfaite
jeu parce qu ils sont dix petits sellers
inc aussi léger mais réel sans strass et
vous clément mais je suis pas bien
physiquement c'est ce que tu veux mais
tu vois pas mes bouts mais c'est
vraiment les beaux gosses quoi doit on
ou à la vente un jeu vraiment ça voilà
c'est ça ce qu'on pense de nous c'est
qu'on joue systématiquement de notre
physique est tous assez sympa du tout ce
que tous les jours il est beau mais
c'est fait exprès c'est ça en fait non
j'ai rétabli la vérité
oui on les voit ils sont beaux ils ont
des abdos nous on n'en a pas mois ci je
suis dit ça pour la can be seen as oui
oui c'est bruce willis avait craqué sur
les braises mais non mais la machine qui
est indéniable mais c'est cette façon et
je veux dire j'ai beaucoup de boue il
est beau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
me passer bon jour mais si on place
alain yannick fred on est loin derrière
choisir parce que c'est cool ça peut
être compliqué car à bord mais où le
vent me pousse heureux d'avoir fait la
voiture quand même moins sûr bien sûr
qu'on est heureux
enfin moi je peux avoir moi je fais
chaque fois qu'il vient des tpb bien sûr
qu'ils sont je suis très heureux c'est
vrai en plus pour rejoindre clément et
maintenant parlant et tout ce qu'on a pu
vivre à travers cette expérience c'est
vrai que c'est exceptionnel c'est
magnifique c'est les souvenirs
inoubliables tout au long de notre vie
maintenant c'est plus soit très en
interne
voilà les mariages sont différents les
compatibilités sont différentes aussi
les personnes sont différentes il faut
tout pour faire un monde il faut de tout
pour faire marié au premier regard voilà
comment alors y'a bouder qui me dit il
confiant vous êtes des vrais beaux
gosses et il sait de quoi il parle
vous vous aussi non mais vous n'en avez
vous aussi vous êtes heureux
ah oui bon c'est que je vous me direz
qu'on vous aurez trouvé l'amour voilà
c'est quoi votre style j'ai pas de style
c'est avant tout ces jeux par un feeling
une femme les cheveux j'adore l'élan
cheveux ah oui franchement alors eu la
belle mère vous regardez comment
premiers mois ses yeux pour moi le
regard way le revers pour le regard le
sourire ça en dit long sur l'âme de la
personne devraient très nombreux à
tenter
[Rires]
précisez cellulaire un prêt l'été
ouais c'est ça ta mère elle avait un bon
burger et un beau sourire et non ça
devait être une belle personne pourtant
si on parle que d'eux que du physique
non le physique c'est ça fait pas tout
et secondaire c'est sale ça vous regarde
et provenait ce que je regarde en
premier chez une femme oui oui son âme
de notre gueule longtemps la sphère très
lourd